okay it is time for hatred mail if
you've never heard hatred mail before
hatred mail is I get a ton of hate mail
and we have a deep voice movie announcer
who does interpretive readings of that
hate mail sometimes they are homophobic
sometimes they are anti-semitic they are
always unhinged a quick reminder about
what hatred mail is a fine Rand and
Ronald Reagan had a baby and suckled
that child off the teat of Liberty its
cries would sound a little something
like Patriot man written by Patriots who
hate David Pakman because America
because freedom so this week's hatred
mail like most requires no introduction
but it is timely it relates to sexual
assault allegations and Brett Kavanaugh
and this is actually something I've been
experiencing a lot on Twitter I'll tell
you about it after we listen to this
week's a treemail Pakman is a shill lmao
David Pakman equals shill liar media
[ __ ] Pakman a privileged Jew racist
worse [ __ ] on YouTube David Pakman
touched my penis and tried to rape me
last summer I'm so ashamed but he must
pay I would love to get a group together
to publicly accuse Pakman of gay rape he
print Agra nated me how do you like that
hey oh yeah I can assure you that I've
never printed anybody but this is
actually something that I've been
dealing with on Twitter for the last few
days which is given my position on the
allegations against Brett Kavanaugh
which I find generally credible and I
generally find him to not be credible a
bunch of people on Twitter have started
saying well David we're going to accuse
you of rape and then you'll see what
it's like to which I've been saying go
ahead and try I can assure you that if
you try to do it those allegations will
make absolutely not' we'll get
absolutely no traction because they
would be so obviously false and
there's this idea that any rape
allegation any sexual assault allegation
no matter how incredible becomes
accepted as some kind of fact
immediately that's simply not true
obviously bogus allegations wouldn't go
anywhere which is why I said go ahead
and try to accuse me of some kind of
sexual assault you're gonna get nowhere
you're gonna get nowhere because it will
be obviously not credible what you can
do if you don't like these Patriots if
you don't like this point of view that
they're espousing the coupon code hey
tree at forty if you use it on any
membership on our website wwlp.com
you'll save 40 percent and 166 hey tree
'it's will cry every time you use that
forty percent discount code